[Musica]
[Risate]
dunque iniziamo facendo un breve salto
nel futuro non un futuro qualsiasi ma il
futuro immaginato dal film red i player
one di steven spielberg a qualcuno
l'avrà visto un futuro distopico tanto
per cambiare perché distopico perché in
questo 2045 a causa di una crisi
energetica
le persone stanno male e allora si
rifugiano in un mondo virtuale dove
hanno la maggior parte delle loro
relazioni dove fanno la maggior parte
delle loro cose quindi smettono di
vivere nel mondo reale e iniziano a
vivere in questo mondo virtuale
adesso torniamo al 2021 cioè torniamo al
presente è un pochino è diventato un
brutto posto anche il presente
soprattutto nell'ultimo anno a causa
della pandemia
e allora la maggior parte delle nostre
relazioni si sono svolte nella sfera del
virtuale ora un po meno speriamo che
continui a migliorare però sappiamo
tutti quello che sto parlando ovviamente
parlo di una sfera del virtuale che è
molto diversa da quella che abbiamo
visto nel film di spielberg
anzi non parliamo neanche di virtuale la
parola che usiamo è di stanza il lavoro
a distanza scuola a distanza è certo
siamo tutti ben contenti che le
tecnologie ci abbiano permesso di fare
tutta una serie di cosa distanza
basterebbe solo immaginarsi cosa sarebbe
stata una pandemia 20 o 30 anni fa senza
internet no spero dopo un anno e mezzo
la presenza ci comincia a mancare ecco
siamo tutti ben contenti di fare un po
di cose in presenza di più contenti di
tutti sono le persone che hanno a che
fare con la scuola
questo è un grafico di un'indagine che è
stato fatto dal mio istituto e dire è
che mostra la qualità percepita della
didattica a distanza da parte degli
insegnanti non c'è da capire tutte
quelle cose sono tutte quelle barrette
ci basta vedere in che verso vanno cioè
verso il basso quasi tutte le dimensioni
dell apprendimento sono peggiorate nella
didattica a distanza nell'opinione dei
docenti tranne una quella verde che va
in su e che l'autonomia e la
responsabilità degli studenti
quella è migliorata tutto il resto è
peggiorato e non di poco
quindi l'opinione comune è che la
didattica debba essere fatta in un luogo
fisico perché la didattica in un luogo
fisico la didattica in presenza è
migliore di quella distanza e non solo
la didattica è perché quante volte
sentiamo dire i ragazzi stanno troppo su
internet bisognerebbe che uscissero di
più perché si dedicassero in questo modo
alle relazioni vere e qui bisogna
chiedersi però ormai le relazioni a
distanza sono meno vere anzi cosa si
intende per relazioni vere
forse si vuole dire che la presenza è
forse il medium più potente che c'è e
che tutto il resto è una versione è e
continuerà a essere una versione
degradata di delle relazioni in presenza
ora per rispondere a queste domande io
vorrei tornare un attimino nel futuro
in quel 2045 descritto dal film red i
player one però questa volta non il film
il libro da cui il film è stato tratto
perché nel libro c'è un capitolo che
descrive una normale mattinata in classe
di un adolescente che va a scuola
e allora questo adolescente indossa dei
visori si immerge in una realtà virtuale
in cui ci sono i suoi compagni di classe
l'insegnante che spiega solo che a un
certo punto il teletrasporto a visitare
la tomba di tutankhamon e poi su marte
analizzare il suolo marziano ora capite
bene che queste sono cose che nel
presenza non si possono fare e allora
forse varrebbe la pena non solo
paragonare la distanza a quello che si
può fare in presenza perché questo ci
porta a considerarla sempre comunque il
parente povero della presenza ma pensare
a quello che l'a.d
stanza qual è il valore aggiunto della
distanza le cose che a distanza si
possano fare e in presenza no ora magari
qualcuno si starà chiedendo ma queste
cose che ci hai fatto vedere sono così
state fatte al computer due già esistono
ma in realtà esistono già cioè le cose
che abbiamo visto in questi ultimo video
sono tecnologie che esistono già al
giorno d'oggi la prima parte di quel
video è una tecnologia sviluppata dai
farm che è una piattaforma di
innovazione che risiede a 20 chilometri
da qui da dove da dove ci troviamo
adesso però facciamo degli esempi anche
meno futuristici in realtà delle scuole
a distanza
esistono già da qualche anno eccone una
per esempio si tratta di una università
i cui i corsi si frequentano da remoto
sono corsi che non esisterebbero nella
tua città
anzi in molti casi non esistono neppure
in italia
quindi se uno li volesse frequentare in
presenza dovrebbe trasferirsi all'estero
che non è una brutta cosa è però se ai
mezzi economici per farlo perché
altrimenti le cose si complicano un bel
po no e allora poter frequentare un
corso a distanza significa poter
frequentare delle università e non solo
lo vedremo che altrimenti non potresti
frequentare
e poi ci sono tutta una serie di
categorie che non potrebbero frequentare
altrimenti pensiamo adulto che ha una
famiglia che ha un lavoro a tempo pieno
e che non potrebbe frequentare una
scuola in presenza perché ha bisogno di
una flessibilità di tempi ed i modi che
la scuola in presenza difficilmente
ricordare
facciamo anche degli altri esempi perché
ad esempio non so se lo sapete ma in
italia non solo ci sono una serie di
piccoli centri abitati semi isolati
pensiamo alle piccole isole o anche a
dei centri montani
questo è un esempio cosa sta succedendo
da qualche anno a questa parte che
diventa difficile fare scuola in questi
piccoli centri
perché non ci sono abbastanza studenti e
allora la scuola va in crisi le famiglie
si spostano e il motivo
la causa è soprattutto la scuola perché
vanno a dover la scuola c'è negli ultimi
anni i governi che si sono succeduti
hanno investito tanto sul ripopolamento
di questi piccoli centri e questo passa
soprattutto dalla scuola perché è chiaro
che se un bambino non riesce a fare
squalifi cilmente potrà vivere in questi
piccoli centri
ecco allora che una scuola a distanza
credibile in cui in qualche modo si
riesce con efficacia a fare didattica
diventa una possibilità per alcune di
sono idee di rimanere in questi centri
per altri addirittura di andarci ad
abitare
ecco siamo arrivati un po al concetto di
democrazia
in questo caso si sta parlando di alcune
forme di didattica a distanza che in
determinati contesti sono più
democratiche della didattica networking
presenza per i motivi che vi ho appena
detto
certo qualcuno si starà pensando va bene
ma qui si parla solo di didattica nella
scuola non ha mica solo questa funzione
qua quella didattica
c'è ad esempio la funzione di
socializzazione secondaria quella
primaria è quella dei primi anni di vita
che avviene in famiglia no poi dopo c'è
una socializzazione secondaria è
affidata soprattutto alla scuola perché
lì che si cominciano a fare nuove
amicizie si allarga la rete sociale
e la scuola anche questa funzione e la
relazione passa da tutta una serie di
canali di comunicazione e ancora
perlomeno ancora non sono stati
sviluppati a distanza e poi c'è una
terza funzione importante nella scuola
ce ne siamo accorti soprattutto in
questo ultimo anno e cioè la custodia
dei minori perché la scuola è quella
cosa che permette che si prende la
responsabilità dei minori e permette ai
genitori che entrambi lavorano di poter
disporre del loro tempo lavorativo avute
in quel momento la responsabilità di
filia affidata ad altri quindi tre
funzioni importanti che sono racchiuse
in uno stesso tempo in uno stesso
edificio
il tempo scuola e l'edificio scuola
forse bisognerebbe pensare a una
relazione a un modello pochino più
flessibile dove queste tre funzioni non
sono per forza racchiusa in uno stesso
tempo e in uno stesso spazio che è
quello dell'edificio scuola però
chiaramente questo è un modello che deve
essere ancora sviluppato e che in
qualche modo pone dei problemi
importanti
poi c'è un altro problema perché della
didattica a distanza perché una delle
obiezioni più grandi che gli viene fatta
è che non è democratica non è
democratica perché bisogna investire in
tecnologia bisogna avere le tecnologie e
allora il rischio è quello che le
famiglie ricche ristorantini che abbiano
le tecnologie migliori e che questo mi
consenta un accesso migliore rispetto
alle altre famiglie quindi una disparità
vero però vorrei fare una domanda voi lo
sapete quante quanto spende una famiglia
per un figlio che studia dal primo
all'ultimo anno di scuola l'ultimo anno
della secondaria
eccolo qua più o meno cioè 40 240 euro
all'anno ma poi alle superiori
la cifra aumenta ho fatto io un po il
totale si va dai 2.100 ai 3.100 euro
nella carriera scolastica del figlio
ci sono delle scuole che hanno decisione
abbattere questi costi lo avrete capito
no si sta parlando di costi per
l'acquisto di libri queste scuole
una in particolare o meglio una rete di
scuola in particolare la rete book in
progress fatta di 300 scuole in tutta
italia che hanno deciso di prodursi in
casa o meglio a scuola i libri di testo
sono gli insegnanti che scrivono ai
libri e poi li distribuiscono agli
studenti della scuola e fanno un patto
con le famiglie di soldi che risparmi
per l'acquisto dei libri di testo mi
vuoi investire ti chiediamo di investire
in tecnologie ad esempio per l'acquisto
di tavole che permetteranno poi di
fruire di quei testi che sono stati
prodotti dal dal dagli insegnanti ma
facciamo anche un altro esempio
allora voi sapete conoscete spotify
netflix eccetera eccetera sono
piattaforme di streaming o comunque di
accesso ai contenuti non di acquisto dei
contenuti ma di accesso si paga un tot
al mese per accedere a dei contenuti a
tutti i contenuti
ok o perlomeno a tanti
ecco voi provate a immaginare se gli
editori scolastici si mettessero
d'accordo su un modello commerciale che
prevede li facciamo un esempio un
accesso per ogni studente a una cifra
che potrebbe essere verosimilmente
questa non è al da alcuni libri di testo
i cosiddetti libri in adozione lo sapete
no
l'insegnante adotta un testo ed è quello
che gli studenti acquistano non solo a
quei libri non solo ad un libro di
matematico di fisica
ma a tutti oa gran parte dei libri
questo vorrebbe dire ristrutturare un po
l'accesso alla conoscenza scolastica
poter studiare su una quantità di fonti
molto più ampia
ecco diciamo che arrivati a questo punto
mi sto chiedendo se noi soprattutto in
questo ultimo anno ci siamo fatti la
domanda sbagliata perché la domanda che
si è sentito ai giornali e telegiornali
nei battiti è quanto la scuola distanza
la didattica a distanza riuscisse a
essere all'altezza di quella di presenza
quanto non riesce a fare quanto fa male
quanto non sta facendo la didattica a
distanza
forse bisognerebbe ribaltare la domanda
forse la domanda vera da chiedersi è
questa cos'è che la scuola in presenza
non sta facendo lo sta facendo poco o
sta facendo male
ecco se fosse questa la domanda allora
forse scopriremo che la scuola così come
l'abbiamo sempre conosciuta non è la
scuola migliore
non è la scuola più democratica e allora
scopriremo anche che forse la distanza
nei prossimi anni potrà essere uno dei
nostri migliori alleati
grazie